it is a weird creature stiff pale and
deathly looking a zombie incapable of
movement but all of a sudden in one long
hop it is face to face with you but what
exactly is it there are numerous
vampiric and zombie like creatures that
appear in Chinese mythology and the
creature that we'll be discussing today
is the Jong sure as with many Chinese
influences it is a creature that appears
in several Southeast Asian countries
including Vietnam Korea Indonesia and
Japan the Jong Shura most commonly known
as the Chinese hopping vampire the name
drunk sure itself originates from a
phrase means stiff corpse and this
refers to the fact that they have rigor
mortis rendering him unable to walk so
instead they hop around it was thought
that if one was to knock or push one
over they would never be able to get up
without assistance now this may seem
like a very peculiar a none practical
way to travel so how exactly did these
reanimated corpses come to be one of the
origin stories used to explain the
juncture register how dead bodies would
be transported when someone died far
from their home it would be rather
expensive to transport their body back
to their family to solve this problem
families would instead hire a Taoist
priest to conduct a ritual reanimating
the dead person and then teaching him or
her how to hop their way back to their
family the priest will escort these
bodies back sure in the evening when
they would make their presence known by
sounding a bell this was done because a
person gazing upon a Jong sure was
considered a bad omen
another potential explanation as to how
the Jong show were created is because of
improper death either a suicide or a
murder leaving the individual of
unresolved business and they're so
unable to leave the deceased body there
have been numerous films featuring the
john shaw were being injured by them
causes the victims to be infected with
the jeongjo virus slowly turning them
into one now this is quite a common
trope amongst both zombies and vampires
their physical appearance can vary
drastically as we mentioned earlier they
are essentially a reanimated corpse so a
pale decaying appearance that we would
associate with a corpse can be expected
because they have rigor mortis they
struggled to move their limbs and the
main way they move around is by hopping
while they help around their arms are
stretched out in front of them to
improve balance and mobility this in
itself is another trope that we would
associate with zombies arm stretched
staggering towards the next meal
some Jong sure have long fingernails
that are extremely strong and a paler
screen skin that is believed to be some
kind of fungus growing on the dead
bodies it's thought that the juncture
have no recollection of their previous
life and their behaviors extremely
instinctual closer to that of an animal
than a human it's no surprise that as a
vampire of sorts they prefer to feed off
humans draining their life force but
this can sometimes stretch to animals if
they are desperate to feed when it comes
to hunting their prey it's likely they
use their sense of smell or picking up
on a human's heart rate and breathing
pattern there are several items and
techniques that can be used to avoid the
John Shaw relying on someone's breathing
to track their prey holding ones breath
is an effective way to escape dropping a
bag of coins on the floor is thought the
cause of John I'm sure to stop and count
the coins given the person's plenty of
time to flee sticking at our talisman to
their forehead is another way to
immobilize them for as long as it
remains attached the sound of the
roosters call is said to cause many evil
spirits to withdraw as the roosters call
was usually a sign of the Rising Sun
with many spirits and creatures
particularly the vampiric ones and those
who hunt during the evening the sound of
the call signals the end of the hunt the
jungle sure are a peculiar set of
creatures an interesting mix between a
vampire and a zombie with a ridiculous
and comical form of movement almost
hopping around like a frog
there may be an obscure creature but
they seem to make numerous appearances
in pop culture if you happen to watch
any TV shows or read any mangas where
the John shall make an appearance then
let me know how they're depicted and how
they differ as always I've been your
host mythology and fiction explained
you